Exzellent, Chat, mir ist doch immer wieder aufgefallen wie anstrengend es sein kann
8 Stunden nichts zu machen, unglaublich, unglaublich wie anstrengend das ist jetzt gar nicht gedacht
eigentlich wollte ich heute Abend nicht mehr ankommen
aber ich hab gerade auf die Uhr geguckt und hab mir gedacht es ist 19.03
ne 8, ich kann jetzt nicht mehr die Uhrzeitrichtung lesen, lul
es ist 19.08 da ist jetzt noch genug Zeit
aber es ist echt hart, ne 8 Stunden nichts gemacht und trotzdem übelst kaputt
zumal wir theoretisch was gemacht haben aber das war wie als hätte man nichts gemacht
ganz merkwürdig, und zwar ich hatte heute 8 Stunden Microsoft Azure, Microsoft Azure
und ich sag euch das war so anstrengend weil es überhaupt nicht vom Fleck gegangen ist
ich frag mich immer wie diese Schulungen eigentlich gedacht sind also ist das normal
dass man sich auf diesen Schulungen einfach zu 80% langweilt
ja weil mich heute jemand auf Twitter gefragt hat was ich gemacht hab
hier ich hab heute das da gemacht Azure AZ400 hab ich heute gemacht
das hab ich heute gemacht designing and implementing Microsoft
Devops Solutions, ah yes, exzellent Titel
also Implemented, also designt haben wir heute schonmal gar nichts
und Implemented, ja lasst mal überlegen, also was haben wir Implemented
eigentlich auch nichts, also überlege heute Mittag haben wir einen Test gemacht
oder weil es kein Test ist wie heißt das da so ein Übungs Lab gemacht
wo es drum ging, dass man irgendwelche komischen Kanban Boards in Azure zusammenklickt
ganz merkwürdig was auch immer das mit Devops und äh Dings
Kanban Board das ist ja so der neueste Agile Shit wieder
im Prinzip ist ein Kanban Board nichts anderes wie ne Tafel mit Zettel dran
aber das ist jetzt agil und besser Tafel mit Zettel ist out
Kanban Board ist in obwohl es genau das gleiche ist im Endeffekt
so sowas ist ein Kanban Board hier guckt es euch mal an
also im Prinzip sowas wo drinnen steht genau was gemacht werden muss
was gerade gemacht wird und was fertig ist also es ist ne Tafel mit Zettel unterm Strich
so triffts das hier eigentlich auch ganz gut so und oh der Ventress hat abonniert 3
monat dankeschön exzellent Subscription ich hab heute keine Energie mehr
Tour und Tour zu spielen das krieg ich heute nicht mehr gebacken
ich hatte bis 17 Uhr Microsoft Schulungsgedöns und es war ultra langweilig
Wahnsinn zumindest so da fragt man sich warum richten wir als die ultra krassen Devops
Pros irgendwelche Kanban Boards in Microsoft Azure ein
huge innovation ja das hat es mir überhaupt nicht erschlossen
zumindest hab ich heute gelernt dass wenn man ein Projekt anlegt in Azure man aufpassen
muss dass man es richtig anlegt weil man kann in Azure auch Projekte falsch anlegen
also wenn man jetzt sich jetzt denkt ok wie soll das funktionieren ich mein wenn man
ein Projekt anlegt dann ist es angelegt nein nein nein nein nicht so in Microsoft Azure
ähm weil die Sache ist die wenn man sich in ein Account anlegt und man
äh sorry nicht Projekt Organisation das ist aber das übergeordnete anlegt und man hat
aus Versehen seine sein Outlook Konto ausgewählt dann geht das auf das Outlook Konto und wenn
man den Microsoft Azure Schulungsgenerator verwendet der verwendet nicht das Sachen die
auf dem Outlook Konto sind sondern man muss vorher auf Default Directory umstellen alles
klar Leute oder klingt logisch naja gut mir nehmen auch sei voll für eine Arsch mega
langweilig ey ich hab mal wieder Anfälle gekriegt guckt euch das mal an pass mal auf
die offizielle Microsoft Schulungs vm oi ja so das war die Microsoft Schulungs vm und
heute morgen irgendwie was mir mal aufgefallen ist Max FPS meine meine Posts meine Posts
auf Twitter sind nicht so sonderlich abwechslungsreich ja wenn man sich hier mal anguckt was ich
hier poste wenn man sich hier meine Medien Posts anguckt KQW irgendwas komisches meine
Katze 5 hat irgendein andere meme gedöns pepo fett monka es easy clap irgendein sinnvolles
Bild noch mal meine Katze pass auf exile Bild der pedo bear 5 hat ein Chat Chat was
habe ich für den Chatverlauf gepostet ach ja das war lust das war ein Chatverlauf auch
von der Arbeit irgendeiner hat er gerne meine meine Kommentare in Teams geliked ich kann
sie ja ja ja ja ja ja mit den leuten noses so excellent 5 hat emote ok trends db db emote
oh wie mit mir geht nicht wie warum kann ich nicht weiter zurück in der history naja zumindest
sind meine tweets nicht sonderlich abwechslungsreich wie es aussieht ja zumindest kann ich es
gerade noch mal auflassen heute morgen also ich hasse es ja auf solchen Schulungen wenn
man sich vorstellen muss das ist immer so zu gezwungen ja wahnsinnig und zumindest heute
morgen war das so ich hab sie hier schon aufgeschrieben ich war zu spät für die Schulung
ein bisschen paar Minuten woran lag das ganze nicht an mir ich war schon 8 uhr 45 oder 8
uhr 40 oder so online dass der Schulungsveranstalter keine link mitgeschickt hat die haben keine
link mitgeschickt wo die Schulung überhaupt ist also da stand einfach ja wir laden hier
hier willkommen heute Schulung aber nirgends wo stand wo das ist übrigens gewiss der end
wo bloß dabei schreiben wenn er was wissen wollt ja was gut wird was ist denn so zumindest
ich habe bei der hotline angerufen von dem Schulungsveranstalter und die hotline vom
Schulungsveranstalter hat mir gerade gesagt dass die Schulungsveranstaltungs hotline gerade
nicht verfügbar ist so habe ich dann geguckt ungefähr aber ich habe glück ich bin ja
nicht alleine da gewesen sondern ein kollege war auch noch am start und der hat eine mail
gefunden von der letzten Schulung die beim gleichen anbieter war dort war ein einladungslink
drin und dann sind wir über den alten einladungslink in die schulungsplattform und haben dort dann
auch den kurs von heute gefunden oder komme ich rein in diesen raum und das erste was
ich höre ist ich soll mich vorstellen ich ich bin auf ich bin 20 minuten vorher aufgestanden
ich komme in den raum rein und denke mir so okay was ist hier los so viele leute schon
am start und alle und alle irgendwie schon am labern und so und auf einmal sei ja maximilian
stell dich doch mal vor leak name leak jetzt ist raus stelle ich doch mal vor dann wollte
er noch so komische dinge wissen wie was was man denn so macht und was man und was man
so geiler und was man sich hofft aus der schulung mitzunehmen wo ich mir gedacht habe okay ich
bin seit fünf fünf sekunden in dem raum drin ich habe keine ahnung was heute überhaupt
rankommt aber was erhoffst du dir mitzunehmen für die schulung ich habe mir da irgendwas
aus den fingern gesaugt ja ich habe irgendwas erzählt ich bin als devops engineer am start
und mache irgendwelche deployments irgendwas zusammen gewurstet ja aber ich hasse solche
vorstellungsrunden diese vorstellungsrunden sind der größte shit überhaupt ich verstehe
den sinn von diesen vorstellungsrunden gar nicht ehrlich gesagt was ist der sinn von
vorstellungsrunden auf einer schulung wohlgemerkt auf dieser schulung sind leute ist ein kollege
von mir gewesen leute irgendwelche komische gemischungen aus irgendwelchen consultants
und in einer firma von der ich im leben noch nichts gehört habe und noch irgendwas und
am besten war ja okay also doch ein paar leute haben mich verwirrt irgendeine aus der aus
rumänien die das war geil vorstellungsrunde und da war ein grill aus rumänien dabei und
die sagt dann ja ich bin ja einfach mal da um mir das anzugucken ich setze aktuell kein
microsoft azure ein und habe auch nicht vor in zukunft microsoft azure einzusetzen was
macht die denn auf der azure schulung was macht die da ja aber aber hauptsache hauptsache
hauptsache geld erstmal raushauen ja zertifikat auf vorrat dann hatten wir noch ein inda dabei
wo ich nicht genau wusste was da von der vornamen und der nachname ist naja gut und
warum muss man sich da vorstellen ich kenne die leute nicht ich werde die nie wiedersehen
das ist total total sinnlos ja und nebenpatrick wie es gab keine rede ball in dem sinn aber
so ähnlich der hat immer das immer immer das wort an ein übergeben so nach dem motto
ja maximile jetzt sagt doch du auch mal vorstellungsrunde ganz eklig leute ich sage euch der index
nicht peter und war nicht von microsoft sofort nein ganz schlimm leute ganz schlimm vorstellungsrunde
naja zumindest habe ich jetzt den ersten tag hinter mir az 400 designing implementum microsoft
devops solutions poggers wahnsinn so und ansonsten muss ich sagen aber doch eine sache war auch
noch geil da war so ein richtiger buzzword mensch dabei der hat sinngemäß erzählt dass
sie leute das ist also das ist fast eins zu eins zitat ich krieg das nicht mal ganz zusammen
aber im kern schon und zwar er hat gesagt er macht agile industrie 4.0 big data jetzt kein
witz ohne spaß agile industrie 4.0 big data ist natürlich gut eigentlich hätte man in
der sache fragen müssen ok was genau versteht man da drunter was ich aber noch gesagt habe
agile industrie 4.0 big data alles klar jetzt jetzt wissen wir bescheid und das entgegengesetzte
war warum kein blockchain auch stimmt soll ich immer frage ich ihn morgen mal ich weiß
nicht mehr wer das war aber das war der einzige der industrie 4.0 macht den frage ich mal
wer war das noch mal mit mit industrie 4.0 und ob die ob die sich auch schon für eine
blockchain lösung entschieden haben und der andere war auch geil es gab zwei extrem wie
gesagt der eine buzzword mann und der andere den war das alles egal und er hat nebenbei
erzählt dass sie noch windows 95 einsetzen auch kein witz leute ich weiß ich klingt
als hätte ich mir genau pains jam der mauszeiger highlight ist gerade richtig ich weiß es klingt
als hätte ich mich ausgedacht aber nein hat gesagt die haben sie das systeme die sind
30 jahre supportet oder so die verwenden auf windows 95 ich weiß zwar nicht was das mit
asher zu tun hat wenn ich ehrlich bin ja was auch immer auf pains jam nicht industrie 4.0
und windows 95 waren zwei unterschiedliche unterschiedliche typen naja zumindest also
wir haben wir haben als erstes so eine ganz merkwürdige übung gemacht wo man wo man
gucken wo man so komische kanban boards krasse kanban boards in asia eingerichtet hat und
danach wollte er von uns wissen wie wir es fanden da habe ich mir okay max du bist jetzt
einfach mal ehrlich und habe ich gesagt also ich fand es jetzt ich fand es jetzt ein bisschen
langweilig weil vor allem gerade so als linux mann bin ich halt so das web interface rumgeklickt
nicht gewöhnt aber ich freue mich schon auf die nächsten schritte wenn wir da ein bisschen
was machen von dem was mir auch was was ich täglich auch mache ja und die die zweite
übung die mir gemacht haben die war halt auch im prinzip absolut low brain wir sollten
und das ey microsoft das ist so extrem kompliziert ich kann euch das jetzt gar nicht zeigen nur
so nur so ansatzweise weil ich habe kein ich kann mich ja ich kann mich ja in meinem meinem
account hier nicht einloggen aber die es gab das nach gab es eine übung man sollte sich
im escher also das ist in dieser in diesem testprojekt schon drinnen also man kann sich
für escher übung so ein demo projekt generieren lassen immer wieder neu und da ist auch ein
git repo drinnen und die letzte übung die wir gemacht haben von 50 ohne scheiß da sieht
man mal wie low brain diese ganze geschichte ist von 15 uhr 30 bis 17 uhr also man denkt
sich jetzt da kommt die wahnsinnige highly sophisticated big brain excellent demo ne wir
sollten uns der tanzer geht wieder ab dankeschön fünf stück insgesamt 120 abos meine güt war
das immer fünf stück habe ich jetzt nicht verzehrt ja doch hier fünf stück stufe eins abos
dankeschön tanzer wer kriegt denn was andy techie kriegt was kreid willhelm solskja 1904 manu
krass takoff und pluton an excellent subscriptions musik nicht ein bisschen laut
ticken leiser ticken leiser so ist besser ja schon dass sie alle am startzeit schon das
der tanzer so viele subs gifted oh nein jetzt gehts wieder los jetzt gehts aufhören leute
schluss jetzt genug für heute wir machen heute wir machen heute kein subwettstreit oder sowas
dankeschön patrick auch bei dir für die fünf subs wer kriegt denn bei dir was thk oder oder
eigentlich ist es ja i underscore thk underscore i ich kenne das auch von den quickscope namen
auf xbox live da muss man ganz besonders korrekt sein was das ganze anbelangt user 32 dl das
gefährlich user 32 dl muss man aufpassen da hat man mit 9908 den kenne ich der schlaft das
dabei gewesen er hat auf jeden fall verdient der true mofos ist auf das dabei und der morris
den kenne ich auch der name sagt auch irgendwas user 32 dl ist auch öfters dabei habe ich auch
schon öfters gesehen leute hört auf es reicht jetzt sonst leute wenn ihr es nicht lassen könnt
wenn ich es nicht lassen kann ohne miss jetzt wenn jetzt heute nicht lassen könnt ja dann
mache ich einfach heute falls das geht donations aus heute nicht eben durch das fürs wochenende
aufwärtig ein bisschen fitter bin wenigstens ja aber tenser verschenkt noch mal von abos ja
big brain subs der iq platzt ja heute heute ist wirklich explodieren der explodieren der
kopf angesagt ich finde ich finde das passende gift dazu gar nicht wo habe ich denn hier der
iq ist so hoch dass es das kann bleibt schon nicht mehr in mir drin tänzer dankeschön fünf stück
und wer kriegt denn jetzt was der wasserfreak 20 rico j nicklas 2 iva t mario der trader die
kenne ich alle sind alle öfters schon da gewesen allesamt verdient exzellent
dein gesicht spiegelt sich in der wolke oben rechts liegt wir brauchen auf jeden fall wenn
ich mir mal endlich emote machen lassen ein liegt im out und dazu habe ich mir schon was überlegt
ich mache wirklich ein foto von mir aber da mache ich halt nur so ein auger ausschnitt und das wird
dann verpixelt und es gibt dann liegt im out und irgendwann mache ich auch noch ein frisil rein
weil zumindest muss er ja mal ein bisschen verebigt werden auf seinem channel wenn er
selbst keine maus hat es ist ein wunder dass max noch nicht richtig geleakt wurde stimmt überhaupt
nicht du hast bloß nicht gefunden ich würde schon an einigen stellen geliegt die meisten
haben glaube ich nicht mitgekriegt dass ich das bin aber es ist an einigen stellen beim
nvidia da bestimmt auch irgendwo ein battlefield event beim nvidia event ach was auch immer
überall zumindest um jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen sache die wo war ich gerade stehen geblieben was
wollte ich jetzt gerade erzählen genau ich habe anfälle gekriegt bei der anderen übung die wir
da gemacht haben geht technisch und zwar wie gesagt von 15 uhr 30 hier äsher schulung von 15 uhr 30 bis
17 uhr sollten wir den repo klonen da drinnen kommen machen den branche machen uns die history
angucken den branche mörchen und noch einen komment machen das alles ist alles das war
ist ohne scheiß alles also im prinzip das was ich morgens zwischen bett und aufs klo gehen mache
ungefähr so und das war alles aber aber wie kompliziert das ist ihr glaubt es nicht normalerweise
ist das normalerweise ist das ziemlich einfach du nimmst du gehst irgendwo hin keine ahnung
sei es mit backend githab githab was auch immer nimmst du die url wurde ein repo klonen kannst wenn
du es ganz oldschool machen willst einfach ssh von einem anderen repo sonst wo nimmst du dir geht
klonen enter vielleicht musst du noch credentials eingeben oder du hast den ssh key schon eingetragen
alles gut geht geklont machst auf der kommando zeile aber dieses lab das nennt sich ja alles lab
bei äsher schulung wusste ich eigentlich dass äsher ärger auf hessisch heißt wenn du dich
äsherst dann hat es nichts mit der cloud zu tun sondern du ärgerst dich educational stream heute
wieder zumindest wie man das wie man das mit äsher macht ist übelst also so abgefuckte
scheiß ich versuche euch das mal ob ich das euch irgendwie zeigen kann als erstes muss man
sich mal extensions dafür instillieren geht sonst nicht ja also habe ich überhaupt geht
geht schon installiert ok also erstes muss man sich mal äsher repo installieren äsher repos
man man erkennt schon die absolut high quality extensions hier mit zwei von fünf sternen
obwohl sie microsoft eigene eigene sache ist wobei ich kann es euch nicht zeigen ich kann mich jetzt
nicht einloggen aber man kann das ähm patrick ich weiß dass das anders geht aber das ist ja
das offizielle übungs lab von microsoft da machen die das nicht über cli so und danach muss man hier
team aufmachen und sein in dann muss man so ein komisches token generierungsverfahren machen so
und danach möchte dieses tutorial von dir oder dieses dieses übungs lab von dir dass du über
dieses über dieses source control menü hier im visual studio gehst und es ist langsam es das
darüber zu machen es ist so eklig ich habe eine halbe stunde gebraucht bis ich überhaupt visual
studio dazu überredet habe das repo zu klonen ganz eklig na machst du das cli kommando zeilen
mäßig kopierst du das tag drückst enter gibt sie credential ist fertig total einfach aber nicht
nicht so hier nicht so bei den asia leuten sehr gut also immer wieso billig ist das das
geht fünf tach um ist es so billig language japanese chinese korean aber englisch auch
aber das ist nur ein ach exam ach der test ach der test das ist nicht die schulung das ist der test
schwachsinn alles naja zumindest das haben wir heute gemacht und kann man bords hin und her
geschoben ja ich habe übrigens habe ich glaube jede menge fragen übersehen hier et
also wir haben hier ich habe eine verständnis frage ich hoffe ich hoffe du bist doch du bist
noch da weil du hast nämlich gerade ein abo gesponsert bekommen glaube ich habe eine
verständnis frage zum reverse proxy und letzt ein kript zertifikat ich nutze war das wieder
jetzt gerade windows was war das warum hat die helft vom fenster gefehlt also ich habe
eine verständnis frage zum reverse proxy letzt ein kript zertifikat ich nutze zu hause
bitthorn und möchte es verschlüsselt intern betreiben es soll nicht vom intern erreichbar
sein ich verbinde mich nur über vpn macht es dann sinn ein zertifikat intern für meinen
bitthorn so aber auszustellen naja also wenn du nur über vpn drauf zugreift oder nur intern
dann ist es jetzt würde ich sagen nicht so essentiell dass deine kommunikation zwischen
dem bitthorn server und deinem client verschlüsselt ist so und gleich die frage weg monkeis naja
also brauchst du nicht ich finde es aber eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt sich das mal ein bisschen
mit letzt ein kript anzugucken ich habe jetzt weiß nicht wer matze 20 90 oder so weil das
gefreut hat es ist gar nicht so verkehrt sich das das mal anzugucken aber braucht man nicht
unbedingt oh guck mal hier ja stimmt du brauchst du wirklich nicht wenn du das intern verwendest
big data ist schon lange durch ja aber der dann war er nicht aktuell der typ war nicht
nicht so ab ab to date mal gucken dass ich hier nichts über sehe stimmt ja das hat sich
jetzt aber glücklicherweise erledigt sprich da etwas gegen letzt ein kript ne du darfst
nicht master branch brauchen das ist rassistisch rassistisch zum glück hat sich das erledigt
mittlerweile das hat sich zum glück die diskussion sind zum glück durch ja es gab ja ein paar
projekte auf github die haben ihre ihre branches umbenannt die haben das von master in main
umbenannt weil master branch ist ja sklavenhaltung und rassistisch und so wir leben in einer
komischen zeit ich gebe es zu ja wo technische sachen umbenannt werden weil irgendwer irgendwo
mal irgendwas gemacht hat was man eventuell damit und fünf ecken in verbindung bringen
kann aber ok zum glück ist es bei den meisten projekten wieder vom tisch
und was hat kann man mit devops zu tun ne das ist halt teil von diesem github github
bucket ticket system klohn den sie intern in der azure devops noch mal haben oder hast
du auch ein kanban board mit dabei wie heißen noch mal deine kameras aber wohlgemerkt ich
empfehle nicht sie zu kaufen sag ich gleich dabei ich hab davon welche die kleinen da
die haben magnetboten das ist ganz praktisch und die da jeweils äh ja die da jeweils
fünf stücke kauft aber erstens mittlerweile sind die sogar auf amazon.com zu teuer bist
du auf der suche nach einer usv ja mittlerweile sind die sogar bei amazon.com zu teuer ich
hab die gekauft als die irgendwie 30 dollar gekostet haben viel zu viel zu teuer äh außerdem
lohnt sich das noch weniger die in deutschland zu bestellen weil da kosten die das gleiche
in euro und das sind sie definitiv nicht wert kosten die 25 dollar 35 dollar für die pan
tilt äh kamera übrigens zoom ist nicht wirklich drin das ist fake news hier dann ist ok ähm
ich hab mir halt ne fünfer pack davon bestellt ne fünfer pack davon als es halt noch günstiger
war viel zu teuer und man muss sagen die sind nicht sonderlich robust die kameras also ich
hab jetzt ja welche im einsatz und ich hatte ja auch eine außen stehen und dort ist letztens
der micro sd kartenslot ich weiß nicht durchgeschmort oder sowas geht einfach nicht mehr also man
man kriegt im endeffekt was man bezahlt wenn man die nur im haus verwenden will ist das
ist das vollkommen ok sind die auch ganz gut aber wie gesagt nicht für den preis da würde
ich irgendwas anderes kaufen für den preis lohnt sich das wirklich nicht das ist viel
zu teuer und außerdem sind die nur gut mit custom firmware und die neuen gehen angeblich
nicht mal mit custom firmware also da muss man aufpassen würde ich würde ich jetzt würde
ich jetzt nicht kaufen sprich was ging letztendlich nee ja wie gesagt bin ich also ich bin nicht
auf einer suche nach einer usw sondern ich ich bin entweder auf einer suche nach einer
neuen usw oder einer batterie von einer alten usw mach einfach eine kamera hab ich doch
die kamera für das hof tor ist ein raspberry pi und das ist richtig gut die raspberry pi
cam diese ganz kleine ist das das ist die hier die ganz kleine kamera die da ist das
die ist wirklich futz futz klein man sieht ja auch hier schon und was ich gemacht hab
ist ich hab ja ich musste ja das ding irgendwie so big brain konstruktionen ich da gebastelt
hab die muss ich auch mal ordentlich machen aber ihr kennt ja meine sachen ich sag ja
immer die muss ich mal ordentlich machen dann am endeffekt nicht ordentlich aber also wie
ich das jetzt gemacht habe jetzt folgendes ich habe ein raspberry pi 0 genommen hab die
kamera dran gemacht hab einen großen schrumpf schlauch genommen die dinger sind ja wasserdicht
und einen großen gummi schlauch genommen und hab den raspberry pi samt kamera in den schlauch
gesteckt hab an der stelle wo die kamera hinkommt ein kleines loch weil das hier ist ja wirklich
klein oben ne ist ja wirklich mini ein kleines loch in den schlauch gemacht und der taster
sagt schon ohne scheiß einfach heißkleber dran gemacht so und dann hab ich das ding noch
mit heißkleber am fenster fixiert und jetzt ist gut jetzt hängt das jetzt hängt das
jetzt hängt das in nem in nem schlauch den schlauch hab ich danach noch zugetackert
und es hängt jetzt am fenster an der wand aber aber hier aber auf dachgeschoss also
das heißt also das kann man nicht einfach mitnehmen so und da hängt das jetzt ja und
worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte bei der ganzen sache die kamera hat ja keine also
das hat ist ja hat ja keine infrared nachtsicht geschichten aber was man echt sagen muss
die settings von diesem raspberry pi camera camera controlling diese software diese raspi
still und raspi cam das hat das hat richtig viele optionen und was man machen kann ist
ich habs jetzt so eingestellt tagsüber läuft die kamera full hd oder könnte sein das in
die 27p läuft kann sein das ich ein bisschen runtergestellt hab ist auch egal ich glaub
25 fps und nachts nachts geht die runter auf 2 fps dafür geht die exposure time hoch
und das bild ist nachts ohne irgendwelche nachtsicht infrared leds richtig hell weil
halt auf der straße ne ne lampe steht und wenn du nur 2 fps hast oder 1,5 fps hab ich
glaube ich eingestellt wenn du nur 2 fps hast dann hast du genug exposure time in der
kamera das licht das das lang genug licht reinfallen kann und das bild hell genug ist
ohne nachtsicht led und das ist halt der vorteil wenn man so ein raspberry pi mit der kamera
dran hat dieses settings kannst du halt nicht bei irgendeiner fertig gekauften kamera machen
so also das war war ich echt begeistert wie gut das wie gut das funktioniert nachts ohne
irgendwelche infrared leds wie viele raspberry pies laufen in deinem haus das kann ich dir
sagen da habe ich irgendwo irgendwo ein dokument wo ich mir das aufgeschrieben habe weil es
öfters mal gefragt wird aber ich glaube das habe ich hier in der vm das kann ich dir
gleich sagen ich glaube in der vm hatte ich das ganze dafür erkennt man doch keine gesicht
er wenn da mal ein räuber kommt ja das stimmt dafür habe ich aber die mit nachtsicht im
hof weil der weil der räuber der klingelt wahrscheinlich nicht vorher dafür habe ich
ja im hof noch welche mit mit nachtsicht mit richtig echten infrared dingern die raspberry
pie cam die raspberry pie cam hier habe ich ja nur dass ich erkenne ob einer am tor klingelt
beziehungsweise wer eigentlich habe ich hauptsächlich dass ich erkennen kann ob dhl klingelt oder
ob wieder irgendeiner vom zirkus klingelt das sammeln will oder ob es vielleicht sogar
mein vater ist da kann ich dann immer faken ich bin ich daheim wenn ich das sehe ja naja
so was wollte ich jetzt machen leute raspberry pie so wie habe ich die datei noch mal genannt
pie pie da ist doch nice also kann ich dir sagen was habe ich im einsatz eine kamera
fürs hof tor das raspberry pie zero mit w mit mit wlan für welche usv suchst du ersatz
muss sag ich dir klar ich muss gerade selbst noch mal gucken wie das ding heißt dann habe
ich den im keller für statistik sammeln für die heizung das habe ich jetzt schon total
oft gezeigt und auch erzählt dass es der raspberry pie also die daten kommen vom raspberry pie
im keller und da zieht infos von meiner wiesmann heizung ab also abgas temperatur kessel temperatur
brenner status pumpe bla sonst was ist die kamera hinterm guckloch nee die kamera hängt
im unterm dach unterm dach am fenster und ist bisschen gedreht dass sie halt auch unten
guckt das heißt ich sehe ich sehe nur die köppe von den leuten aber es reicht um zu
erkennen wer es ist und ob es dhl ist oder nicht so also heizung statistik sammeln raspberry
pie der macht noch ein bisschen mehr der hat noch einen temperatur und luftfeuchtigkeit
sensor dran dass ich so weiß was im keller ist weil der keller ist ziemlich feucht bei
uns also der keller ist ja wahrscheinlich weiß ich woran das liegt halt altes gemäuer
ja ziemlich ziemlich feuchter keller und da kann ich gucken ok wie sieht es mit luftfeuchtigkeit
aus wenn luftfeuchtigkeit über 93 prozent geht dann wird das auch angezeigt bei mir
im heim automatisierungs dashboard und muss halt einer runtergehen den keller mal das fenster
ein bisschen lüften der wie ist die heizung angebunden über einen wie ist man opto link
über so ein kabel das stöpselst du vorne an die heizung das geht das ist und das kommuniziert
über über leds mit der heizung und hier ist vorne so ein anschluss an der heizung da macht
man das rein und dann braucht man ein stück software noch auf dem raspberry pie was dieses
protokoll versteht und dann ist gut so dann habe ich noch raspberry pie 3 mit opto pie
an meinem 3d drucker der ist aber kaputt der mag nicht das sieht dann so aus was was 108
ja ok der ist im arsch den muss ich mal neu installieren der hat sich irgendwie verreckt
so dann haben wir noch einen hc 2 der ist im wohnzimmer und macht fernsehaufnahmen fernseh
gucken das ist hauptsächlich dass meine mutter fernseh gucken kann ja tv hat ein fernseh ich
gucke ja kein fernseh ich gucke ja kein fernseh aber die kann sich dann rosa munde pilcher
oder irgendwie so komische dinge angucken und das ist jetzt kein witz die guckt wirklich
so zeug naja für den scheiß muss man halt gebühren bezahlen ok dafür ist das da funktioniert
in kombination mit tv hat end ziemlich gut da dran ist ein dual tuner usb dual tuner und du
kannst jetzt quasi aufnehmen fernseh gucken mit time shift und im frontend ist ein nvidia
schild tv mit kodi drauf am fernseh dran also das ding nimmt wirklich nur auf dass dem übrigens
es hat mich hat mich irgendjemand gefragt von ob ich gerade irgendwelche serien gucke falls
der noch da ist kann er sich einmal kurz weil ja ich habe letztens eine serie geguckt die fand
ich echt extrem gut muss muss man kurz dann sehr laut bisschen für machen schon den neuen x86
oder hat gesehen ja leider hat er einen doofen formfaktor so dass man ihn nicht gebrauchen
kann falls du dir den hc 2 h2 den neuen h2 meinst nutzt du noch next cloud ja aber ich
will es los werden so also weiter im text genau und dann haben wir noch den unify controller
raspberry pi 3 das ist für wlan access points und dort läuft auch die software drauf ist die
musik so laut oder passt eigentlich ganz gar nicht so laut und da ist auch die webcam über die die
kameraüberwachungs software frontend drauf dass ich mir im browser meine ganzen kameras angucken
kann so dann haben wir noch im keller im schallschrank ist noch ein esp 8266 der den stromzähler
ausliest und zwar fürs erdgeschock und fürs erdgeschoss für den ersten ersten stock das
ist ein bisschen trickreich zeige ich vielleicht auch irgendwann mal im stream dann habe ich auch
ein esp 32 an der tür hängen der liest ein paar flora sensors aus das ist sind so bodenfeuchtigkeits
sensoren wo man gucken kann wann man wieder seine blumen auf der terrasse und im hof gießen muss
so ne serienempfehlung zeige ich gleich noch so genau da sieht man dann zum beispiel dass man
im bet an der einfahrt zur garage mal wieder gießen müsste oder so was das ist eigentlich
relativ praktisch das ist mit diesen sensoren hier gemacht man kann so was zwar auch selbst
bauen aber dafür habe ich was fertiges genommen die dinger sind das die habe ich alle bei bengut
gekauft bengut mi flora sensor ich weiß dass die die seite klingt klingt sehr nach gachi bass
da muss man warten bis die dinger im angebot sind die sind manchmal gehen die runter bis auf
elf dollar wobei man sagen muss 17 dollar ist ok weil die haben gerade promotion sale kommt aus
china dauert ein bisschen aber da kann man sich schon mal so ein 10er pack bestellen wenn man so
was machen will ist das etwa der einzig wahre battlefield youtuber nee nee nee nee nee ich
glaube du meinst diesen m4x fps da habe ich da habe ich nur das nur das logo geklaut nee nee
leider leider wäre ich gerne dann würde ich wieder youtube videos machen keck wait zumindest
wer wer ein bisschen plugen hat auf der terrasse oder im hof oder vielleicht sogar auf dem balkon
und wissen will wo er gießt muss wann er gießt muss kann ich diese dinger empfehlen man braucht
auch nicht die offizielle app man kann das ganze mit einem esp 32 auslesen low energy bluetooth
oder ja natürlich bin ich klar ist glaube ich relativ offensichtlich dass ich bin so ok dann
haben wir als letztes noch genau am hof da ist noch ein esp 32 ins hof da auf und zu geht
briefkasten wird demnächst auch noch ein esp 32 reinkommen habe ich immer noch nicht gemacht dann
auch ein bodenfeuchtigkeits sensor über lorra zum auslesen circa 1,2 kilometer entfernt und
neustart rennt wobei so nur ist das gar nicht mehr ein esp 82 66 an der waschmaschine beziehungsweise
ein stimmt nicht ist nicht an der waschmaschine ist am trockner mit rüttelsensor wo man erkennt
ob er fertig ist oder nicht exzellent so jetzt haben wir das genau und zum thema serien empfehlung
irgendjemand hat es doch folgend gefragt ich weiß gar nicht ob derjenige noch da ist warum
benutzt du eigentlich wim net für sie schaab weil sie schaab in wim eklig zu benutzen ist
wim hat keine gescheite autover vollständigung wim hat keine gescheiten reference rumspringen
funktion für dort net man kann das alles nachrüsten mit in einem language server oder sonst was aber
muss halt ehrlich sagen dass selbst die visual studio code implementierung nicht so gut ist also
man muss sagen das beste was es gibt ist rider was code unterstützung angeht bei dort net gefolgt
von visual studio und dann gefolgt von visual studio code language server und zeug und für
dort net ist wim einfach nicht schön zu verwenden genauso serien empfehlung stimmt irgendjemand
hat das freund gefragt und zwar ich habe letztes angefangen eine serie zu gucken und bin mittlerweile
auch durch hat bloß hat bloß sechs folgen oder so das ding fand ich echt gut ich gucke
mich so viele serien ab und zu mal ein bisschen und kann man sich auch bei prime angucken das
war richtig gut was hier steht ist übrigens übelst übelst fail ja das ist kein family
family drama oder wobei ein bisschen schon aber kann ich ja mal den trailer angucken
zumindest geht es darum dass das leben einer englischen familie dargestellt wird von 2000
oder frag mich nicht 2020 bis 2035 und das ist wirklich sehr viele sachen drinne die
man so erwarten würde und wo man sich gut vorstellen könnte dass ich das in zukunft
dahin entwickelt es ist auch wenn es sich überhaupt nicht so ließt es es hat ein paar
richtige also schockmomente nicht in form von horror drinne sondern ein paar dinge wo
man denkt fack damit hast jetzt echt nicht gerechnet so 1984 mäßig ein bisschen ein
bisschen ja ja dann ist es scheiße damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet also folge
4 wer es gesehen hat und und und ein großer vorteil wie ich finde das ist in sich abgeschlossen
es gibt sechs folgen und das war es danach ist vorbei es gibt keine zweite season also
es ist wirklich in sich abgeschlossen und sechs folgen kann man sich mal geben sechs
folgen zu jeweils ungefähr 50 minuten ich fand es richtig gut und es kommt mal ich habe
es hat nicht umsonst 94 prozent likes auf google und 8,4 auf imdb und 98 also daran sieht
man schon das hat ist schon ganz gut ja und ich habe sowohl mir das mal in deutsch angehört
in man zum größten habe ich auf englisch geguckt aber ich habe mir die deutsche synchronisierung
angehört ich finde die ging auch ist das auch lustig gemacht nee gar nicht es hat ein paar
lustige sachen drinne aber das ist keine sitcom oder so das ist wie nennt man sowas
so dist dystopie dystopie wie heißt das distro wie heißt das so ist nee dystopie ja dystopie
meine ich
eine fiktionale in der zukunft spiel der erzählung mit negativen ausgang genau aber es ist wirklich
gut gemacht weil da sind da sind viele sachen drinne die halt wirklich so sein könnten
in zukunft so ja also das kann ich das kann ich euch wirklich empfehlen hast du play mirror
schon gesehen nee habe ich nicht wie gesagt ich gucke gar nicht so viele so viel serien
stells das wollte ich auch mal gucken das soll wirklich nicht schlecht sein war das nicht
sogar eine deutsche serie oder was war das es gibt doch jetzt in eine serie aus deutschland
die tatsächlich mal was taugen soll was war das denn noch mal oder war dann war das dark
ne dann war das dark wo ich echt überrascht bin wo ich mir gedacht habe ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass wir nachdings wie ist das wie ist diese deutsche deutsche hecker serie
amazon wie ist der krab nochmal genau you are wanted alter oh gott ey ich konnte mir
zwei folgen angucken das habe ich nicht ertragen das habe ich das konnte ich nicht das habe
ich nicht ausgehalten hexer hexer zeug so ein bullshit richtiger krab und jetzt wieder
habe ich daran gezweifelt dass sie irgendwie mal eine gescheite serie aus deutschland hinkriegen
aber die soll ja wirklich ganz gut sein
rider hat wim emulation ja
es funktioniert noch gar nicht den briefkasten habe ich den esp den den controller habe ich
noch nicht im briefkasten am start weil ich weiß noch nicht genau mit welcher technologie
ich genau machen will
musst du bei all den sensoren überhaupt aufstehen näher ich muss noch geld verdienen das sagt
ein bisschen ja aber ich bin ja auf den weg zum vollzeit streamer
das mache ich jetzt noch ein ja und dann hör ich wieder auf genauso wie wie auf youtube
ich mache dann einfach nichts mehr
ich habe halt eine neue wohnung würde gern smart home machen am liebsten open source
ohne cloud ja das da sowohl vom frontend her als auch von den support modulen und von der
noob einsteiger freundlichkeit ist das am besten habe ich auch top also das ist rein
als frontend ja wie du dann deine technik machst musst du dir überlegen willst du
hauptsächlich wlan geschichten machen willst du vielleicht was wie seawave einbauen und
was kaufe ich da am besten für hardware du kannst mit dem raspberry pi anfangen wobei
ich dir da dringend empfehlen würde mach eine ssd an deinen raspberry pi dran
irgendeine billige ssd du kannst mit dem raspberry pi anfangen am besten sogar ein 3er reicht
und dann machst du eine ssd dran weil die micro sd karte ist sonst ein bisschen zu schnell
kaputt ja und damit kannst du anfangen und dann ist halt die sache ich kann jedem der
home automation machen will eigentlich nur empfehlen mit sachen anzufangen die einem
am ehesten das leben erleichtern ich habe da ich habe ich weiß ich habe schon öfters
erzählt ich habe das erste was ich damals gemacht habe wo ich auch in diese ganze heim
automation geschichte reingerutscht bin ist ich habe mir eine led lampe in flur gemacht
die immer je nachdem wie viel verspätung mein zug hatte angezeigt den zugstatus angezeigt
also sprich ich habe morgen schon beim aufstehen gesehen ob mal zu pünktlich ist oder nicht
das war das erste was ich gemacht habe und das ist auch eines der sachen die immer noch
was immer noch immer noch was bringt das ist jetzt gar nicht weil dauer home office aber
das ist das ist zum beispiel eine coole sache das heißt man sollte sich immer überlegen
oder ich wollte mit lichtsteuerung anfangen genau also immer das nehmen was einem persönlich
das leben am besten erleichtert ja ja es gibt pc lustig es gibt es gibt viele sachen wenn
jetzt natürlich jemand bis er sagt okay ich mache die sachen gerne manuell dann ja dann
brauchst du das nicht aber zum beispiel das nächste was man zum beispiel machen könnte
ist die rollos automatisch machen oder dein dein stromverbrauch zumindest mal ein bisschen
auswerten und gucken was was da so ist je nachdem es ist es ist ganz ganz unterschiedlich
ja aber sowas wie mit dem briefkasten finde ich zum beispiel ganz nützlich dass man sieht
wenn was drinne ist es ist unterschiedlich es ist wirklich bei jedem unterschiedlich
was er was er für sinnvoll hält beziehungsweise was ihm was bringt deswegen kann ich jedem
nur empfehlen fangt damit an wo euch am meisten was bringt weil dann sieht man auch dann sieht
man auch den den gewinn dadurch ja und fangt nicht mit rgb lampen an ich weiß ich habe
eine rgb lampe und fangt nicht mit rgb lampen an weil man die an und also nein schwachsinn
nicht mit rgb fangt nicht mit wlan glühbirnen mit wlan lampen an weil man die ein und ausschalten
kann das ist fail kauft euch ein relay was man einbauen kann an den lichtschalter dass
man den lichtschalter noch verwenden kann und über seine heim automatisierung die lichte
anschalten kann weil ansonsten muss man immer darauf achten dass man die lichtschalter
nicht mehr verwendet weil man ansonsten das strom zur wlan lampe macht ja shelly das ist
der beste das ist tatsächlich der beste ich finde shelly cloud das ist das finde ich
ist tatsächlich sind das hier die besten unter putz wlan relays nur sowas ja die sind
auch gar nicht so teuer bekommt man ich glaube gerade philips hue kommt bekommt man ziemlich
gut hin ich weiß nicht wie es aktuell aussieht habe ich nicht am start ich glaube aber dass
gerade die ziemlich gut supportet sind da musst du aber mal vorher gucken so wie das
halt ist gibt es da wahrscheinlich auch drei verschiedene varianten wie man das machen
kann ja dann musst du auf manche sachen custom firma drauf machen jetzt bei den lampen nicht
nicht unbedingt aber philips hue müsste eigentlich ziemlich gut funktionieren aber wie gesagt
habe ich nicht genau es muss auch nicht unbedingt zeitsparen sein es reicht schon wenn das angenehm
ist ja zum beispiel eine sache die auch extrem praktisch ist habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran
gedacht eine sache die ich auch extrem praktisch finde ist wenn man an jedem fenster und an
der ausgangstür nen sensor dran hat der einem sagt ob offen oder zu ist das heißt was ich
jetzt mache ist bevor man aus dem haus geht einfach gucken auf das dashboard ob alles
dicht ist fertig da muss man nicht mehr rumlaufen und gucken oh mist max hast du oben im bar
das fenster zu in findest du open hub dazu kann ich nur eine sache sagen zu viel java
ansonsten ist open hub glaube ich auch ganz gut brauchbar ja also das mit diesem fenster
sensor ist auch eine enorm praktische geschichte und man kann man kann ja die ganze sache noch
viel weiter spinnen und das ist ja gerade das wo es dann in richtung automatisierung geht
also alles was ich ja bisher erzählt habe ist noch mehr oder weniger sensor daten einsammeln
und anzeigen lassen man muss manuell dann irgendwas klicken aber was man was man zum
beispiel machen kann und was halt dann auch praktisch ist was was bei mir auch so gemacht
ist wenn ich zum beispiel raus gehe und das erkennt meine heim automatisieren also wenn
sich geht nur wenn ich mein handy dabei habe also sprich wenn meine meine presence detection
erkennt dass ich aus dem haus weg gehe und noch nen fenster offen ist da kriege ich
eine nachricht geschickt über pushover auf mein handy da steht max du hast das fenster
im bar vergessen das ist natürlich praktisch ja erstens kann ich auf einen blick sehen
ob alles zu ist und wenn ich doch mal vergessen habe kriege ich eine puschnachricht auf meinem
handy wo drin steht max umdrehen bar fenster auf das ist natürlich schon ganz nützlich
ja hier ein ganzes haus zeitmeier was hat der denn da oh het slimste huys van der achterhok
ich finde niederländisch macht mich immer so übelst fertig weil man denkt wenn man die
richtigen worte ok mal wenn er redet deutsch und dann doch nicht das ist aber eine stylische
dusche hier sowas wollte ich auch haben ging leider nicht im ersten stock zwar zu schwer
für den ersten stock sowas in der richtung wollte ich eigentlich auch haben als dusche
also ich wollte ich wollte eine dusche haben wo man rein laufen kann hier sowas wollte
ich eigentlich haben sowas wollte ich haben genau das finde ich so nice das ist so wie
schwimmbad ich finde das so ich finde das richtig geil aber das war zu schwer das war
zu schwer für den ersten stock das hat der boden nicht mitgemacht leider sonst hätte
ich mir so ein ding dahingestellt und das bad war nicht groß stimmt stimmt es war zu
schwer und das bad war nicht groß genug da hätte man noch den abstellraum mit zum bad
nehmen müssen vielleicht finde ich auch was interessantes um einen tester mit dem smart
tomm zu verbinden ja klar da gibt es da gibt es ganz ganz viele möglichkeiten es dauert
ein bisschen bis man so in der denkweise drin ist dass einem überhaupt auffällt oh nee
da könnte man ja was cooles machen aber dann gibt es gibt wirklich saumäßig viele varianten
und diese ganze geschichte die man da immer so in fertigen lösungen sieht von wegen smartem
tor türschloss alles blödsinn mit den kleinen sachen anfangen die einem tägliche leben
was bringen typo x dankeschön zwei monate excellent big brain subscription genau also
wie gesagt so was wollte ich mir einbauen lassen leider war das bad also war der boden
zu nicht tragfähig genug dafür und das bad wie ich es geplant hatte zu klein und da hätte
man noch quasi die kam die abstellkammer neben dazu nehmen muss das wollte ich aber ansonsten
finde ich so was extrem so das irgendwann will ich vielleicht baue ich hier irgendwie
noch mal um oder irgendwas dann kommt so was eventuell rein ja das ist nämlich echt nice
da kommst du echt vor allem gerade auch mit dieser in dieser kachel und diesem schwimmbad
das in in schlag ich für den scheiß mit diesen kacheln und so und die dieser wand das ist
wirklich wie wie wenn du im spiel den schwimmbad läufst ich mag auch diese normalen duschkabinen
nicht ja also normalen duschkabinen ist ja so ein ding mit durchsichtlicher wand so ein
ding das ist ja so eine stinknormale so eine ähnliche duschkabine habe ich da jetzt auch
das ist normal durchkabinen und ich finde die dinge unglaublich ungemütlich zum duschen
ja da kommt das ist so ein glas box da stehst du nicht gerne drin die tür ist nicht richtig
dicht weil das so ein komisches klappding ist
da ist es müll es ist müll ich meine ich habe jetzt so ein ding weil ich mein irgendwo
na ich mein gut als gamer warum eigentlich überhaupt ja ab und zu mal könnt ihr ab und
zu mal den fischteich hinten springen oder so
aber
ja in hotels haben alle dieses ding am am nervigsten war mal in so einem hotel aber
da war ich wahrscheinlich einfach zu dumm für
das könnte sogar bei diesem battlefield event in in berlin gewesen sein ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr genau da
musstest du wenn du reinkommst die weißen hotels machen das ja nicht total low end hotels
da kriegst ja mittlerweile so eine karte die du rein stecken musst und nur wenn die karte
rein steckt dann geht klimaanlage fernsee und kram überhaupt an und ich war nicht in
der lage diese klimaanlage auszustellen ich hab es nicht hingekriegt so und wenn du die
raus nimmst geht der ganze kram nicht mehr dann musst du im bist im dunklen bad so ich
war nicht in der lage die klimaanlage auszuschalten ich hab es einfach nicht gebacken gekriegt
ja weil ich war ich war einfach zu blöd für so und da hatten sie so eine komische
klasse dusche in dem hotel und die tür zum bad war auch noch mit so einem komischen spalt
unten wo man sich denkt ist das für die spanner oder so keine ahnung normalerweise kommt
ja da keiner rein aber mit so einem spalt wahrscheinlich dass es besser abziehen kann
ich weiß nicht und ich hab da irgendwie drin gestanden ich hab mir übelst den arsch abgefroren
ganz eklig ja zumindest um mal zurückzukommen das damit dass das das will ich mir nochmal
unbedingt außerdem wird es gut zu meinem big brain dusch klo passen aber man braucht
mal ein relativ großes bad für ist schon nice ist echt nice guck mal also das ist echt
poggers sowas das für ein ultra hässlicher stuhl hier was ist das das sieht aus als
hätte da einer 20.000 zahnpastatum drauf ausgedrückt oder so ein schwamm sieht aus
wie ein schwamm schwamm schwammstuhl was auch immer na gut äh was wusste man den server
rom 830 hat irgendwer geschrieben das hier ah java nee pp oder pp pp oder ok server
rom achtung ok ich guck mal ach so sieht der server rom aus exzellent mit grill im server
rom ok der hat ordentlich verkabelung auch unterm dach oder wo ist das der hat ordentlich
verkabelung drin na gut das sind auch die ganzen schalter und und stromversorgung und
gdns ach so viel mehr strom kosten sind das gar nicht man darf auch nicht vergessen das
richtig gemacht spart das auch ein bisschen strom allerdings es spart nicht mehr strom
als es kostet ja das da also die illusion darf man sich nicht machen es gibt ja leute
die sagen ja jetzt habe ich eine intelligente heizungssteuerung und irgendwie eine intelligente
wärme gedöns und stromzähler und nacht schalte ich geräte aus und so was ja alles
schön und gut aber es wird nie weniger sein als man als es kostet im endeffekt das das
kann mir keiner erzählen was es war nur der namefrei zwei sechs monate dankeschön exzellent
der chat iq ist heute wieder der explodierte ne das auch nein eigentlich wollte ich das
einblenden aber das auch aber das auch so irgendjemand wollte eben noch was wissen zu
sorry falls du schon beantwortet hast ich muss übrigens immer hier nebenbei so was aufmachen
weil ich habe gesehen wenn man hier nebenbei was offen hat neben dem chat dann wirkt das
immer interessanter die leute bleiben mehr dabei so also hier big brain streaming strats
gerade also weiß ich ob du schon beantwortet hast musste doch eine richtige steuer erklärt
muss ich die ganze zeit schon was warum ich steuerberater habe weil ich keinen bock habe
auf den scheiß sorry falls du schon beantwortet hast du meintest dass du dein next cloud abschaffen
willst meine frage ist wodurch das next cloud ersetzen willst ja also erste mal die sache
ist warum ich next cloud abschaffen will ich will next cloud abschaffen weil ich nur einen
ganz kleinen teil von next cloud verwende und ich glaube ich muss sagen ich glaube weil
ich noch nicht alles ausprobiert habe dass es für die teile die ich verwende bessere
alternativen gibt zum beispiel eine sache wofür ich next cloud verwende ist die feilsynch
thematik allerdings muss ich sagen die next cloud app und feilsynch hat mich jetzt nicht
so wahnsinnig überzeugt ich hatte schon mal das problem dass die verbindung zur next cloud
von einem rechner die richtig funktioniert hat und danach war er der meinung also was
gespiegelt zwischen zwei rechnern danach wäre der meinung dass next cloud laufwerk war leer
und hat alle sachen quasi two way gesyncht auf leer was total hängen geblieben ist zum
glück halte ich den kram noch irgendwo und das nächste ist next cloud kann extrem viel
allerdings man muss sagen die qualität der einzelnen produkte ist sehr fragwürdig zum
beispiel hat next cloud hunderttausende plugins apps mittlerweile aber zum beispiel guckt man
sich mal die notes app an totaler müll man kann notizen nicht richtig durchsuchen btw
das ist ein stand von vor einem jahr ich habe mir das jetzt die letzte next cloud version
nicht mehr angeguckt ja oder von einem halben jahr die notes app kann ich richtig suchen
das ding hat bis heute keine richtige volltext suche out of the box integriert man muss da
irgendwie selbst was frickeln mit irgendeinem eigenen solarserver und nicht elastic search
oder ist es mittlerweile elastic search ich weiß gar nicht lucine bla gedöns selbst java
zusammenfuddeln dann hast du so sachen wie die notes app die nicht mal richtig notizen
suchen kann wo es keine desktop varianten dafür gibt dass ich die to do app wurde auch
keine to do ist richtig suchen kannst die irgendwelche nicht offiziellen kalldorf sachen
verwendet also es gibt viele sachen aber es ist alles irgendwie so ein bisschen halbherzig
so und dann habe ich mal geguckt okay unterm strich unterm strich was verwendest du denn
vor next cloud und da bin ich schon zum schluss gekommen eigentlich verwende ich filesynch
eigentlich verwende ich filesynch und kalldorf für kalender das wars ja karta für kontakte
könnte ich auch verwenden aber das wars ich hab ich hab zwar immer wieder vorgehabt die
funktion zu benutzen die next cloud bietet also sprich die ganzen apps die haben ja auch
irgendwie location tracking geschichte und sonst was also die haben schon viele coole
sachen aber immer wenn ich es ausprobiert habe habe ich sofort festgestellt die qualität
der jeweiligen apps plugins und auch vor allem wenn man sehr auf mobile unterstützen guckt
hat mir nicht gefallen so und deswegen bin ich jetzt zu dem schluss gekommen wenn ich
eh nur zwei kleine sachen verwende vor next cloud dann kann ich auch was anderes verwenden
so und jetzt bin ich grad am gucken was ich als sync verwende syncthing habe ich schon
mal ausprobiert allerdings hat mich das verwirrt weil es für mich erstmal so ausgesehen hat
als muss man das immer extern irgendwie über den ihren server vermitteln aber ich hab
jetzt mal nachgeguckt muss man anscheinend gar nicht also was ich da raus geklickt hab
ist ist verkehrt das ist ein kandidat syncthing ist ein kandidat plus ein paar andere sachen
ja da muss ich mal gucken was ist da was es da für für möglichkeiten gibt und für
die kaldav geschichte ist es eigentlich auch ziemlich einfach das gibt es glaube ich zwei
drei vier verschiedene open source server die man einfach mehr oder weniger drauf ziehen
starten kann läuft so fällig und wenn ich die zwei sachen habe und ich quasi die ganzen
tausend sachen die next cloud noch kann gar nicht brauche kommt next cloud wieder weg
so sieht es aus das archiv ist weg unser archiv ist in pap jeder wie er will ich schreibe
ist es so ist flow 690 siehst du ich weiß dass du es nicht ernst meinst aber es scheint
was dran zu sein ingenieurswesen ja muss man muss ja gleich hier big brain techs setzen
max was nutzt du eigentlich für monitor ich habe mittlerweile einen bank you den da habe
ich mittlerweile seit zwei monaten ja den da habe ich seit zwei monaten ungefähr ist
ziemlich gut für gaming bereich wenn ich jetzt bilder bearbeiten würde oder möchte
dass die sachen besonders druck echt aussehen oder so würde ich das ganze nicht verwenden
ich habe die seitenteile nicht dran habe ich nicht daneben habe ich noch einen iso monitor
stehen der nur 60 herz hat aber dafür ist der richtig gut kalibriert und auch ziemlich
farb echt 1080p ja wenn man 240 herz spielen will und hauptsächlich multiplayer also komplett
competitive multiplayer sachen spielt und man quasi 240 dann brauchen wir keine höhere
auflösung weil beides kriegst du eh nicht zusammen zumindest aktuell noch nicht zukunft
wahrscheinlich auch nicht merkst du einen unterschied zwischen 144 herz und 240 herz
ja aber bei weitem nicht so viel wie bei dem schritt davor und auch nicht so konsistent
weil du brauchst ja erstmal ein game was was ansatzweise so viel fps hin kriegt ja wo
schafft man bitte 240 in overwatch zum beispiel aber ich spiele kein overwatch so und also
overwatch spiele ich nicht mehr das da bin ich durch mit allerdings man hat also muss
ich jetzt mal ein bisschen auswählen also wenn du 240 herz monitor hast das game muss
keine 240 fps schaffen dass man einen vorteil davon hat 240 herz heißt ja nichts anderes
dass der monitor 240 mal die sekunde neue bild infos quasi abruft und darstellen so
ganz billig gesagt abrufen kann und darstellen kann so und das bringt einem natürlich auch
was wenn das spiel nur mit sagen wir 150 fps läuft aber man halt eine größere chance
hat dass der zeitraum zwischen bild ist da und bild wird angezeigt auf dem monitor verkürzt
also man hat schon einen vorteil zum größten teil theoretischen vorteil ja mit 240 herz
monitor auch wenn das spiel nicht mit 240 herz läuft allerdings ist es natürlich besser
wenn das spiel auch mit vielen fps mit viel fps läuft am besten 240 fps plus und ja wenn
es das spiel erreicht was beispielsweise in warzone nicht so oft ist aber in battlefield
3 und 4 konstant erreicht wird was für musik läuft da gerade kingdom hearts so und dann
merkt man es aber wie gesagt der unterschied ist nicht so groß und ich habe auch diesen
diesen die eck oder wie das heißt modus eingeschaltet der sorgt dafür dass die hintergrundbeleuchtung
rein und ausgeschaltet wird mit frame refreshed das hat einen ähnlichen effekt wie auf dem
röhren monitor wo das bild ja auch kurz mal dunkel war röhren monitor wurde aufgebaut
von links oben nach rechts unten und dann ist es quasi wieder schwarz geworden das
ging wie wird wieder neu aufgebaut und das alles in kombination ich finde schon dass
man es merkt aber es ist kein vergleich zu 60 244 fps wirklich gar kein vergleich also
60 244 fps erkennst du quasi im handstand aus 30 meter entfernung während du gerade
irgendwelche nudel futterst und mit einem augen auf den monitor kuckst und jetzt übertrieben
zu sagen da erkennst du den unterschied zwischen 60 fp mit zwischen 60 herz und 144 herz der
unterschied zwischen 144 herz und 240 herz ist bei weitem nicht so offensichtlich aber
man spürt man merkt das aber ich würde ich würde nicht so weit gehen dass man sagt oder
dass dass ich sagen würde wer ernsthaft spielen will muss das haben das würde ich nicht sagen
wer vielleicht jetzt da irgendwie competitive ambitionen hat oder irgendwie sich gerne einbildet
er hat jetzt gerade durch den ein frame vorsprung verloren für den ist es was ich habe lieber
mehr aufwuchs als mehr herz es ist ganz unterschiedlich je nachdem was man haben will es gibt jetzt
ein 360 herz monitor ja aber da warte ich erstmal ab ja und freesync ist ähnlich dass
es eben auch direkt das bild dann anzeigt wenn es von der grafikkarte gerendert ist aber
das bringt bei 240 herz dann vielleicht ein bisschen weniger also da muss ich auch ganz
unglücklich fallen dass du damit freesync noch großartige vorteile hast der kann übrigens
auch freesync und schiessync alles in einem ja sehe ich auch so und ob auflösung oder
mehr refreshing von monitor haben will das ist geschmackssache will man spielt man hauptsächlich
irgendwelche singleplayer spiele spielt man beispielsweise mag man irgendwie irgendwie
assassin's creed in 4k oder in widescreen oder sonst was in der richtung klar dann auf
jeden fall die auflösung spielt man irgendwie die competitive multiplayer geschichten dann
eindeutig mehr fps das striker das stimmt nicht wie oft soll ich das ganze denn noch
erzählen das auge sieht nicht 24 fps das auge sieht 12 fps du kommst nur mit zwei augen
auf 24 chat wie oft habe ich das schon erklärt und es gibt immer noch leute die haben es
nicht verstanden schlimm lowbrain gerade
richtig ich habe auf der arbeit auch einen 4k monitor ja gut da hat gerade noch mal gerettet
aber daheim habe ich lieber das set ab aus zwei monitoren aus 2080p monitor und einem
der halt richtig gut für spiele ist
kann das chat scrollen mal was hältst du von juby key gut allerdings ich würde kein juby
key nehmen sondern das andere ich habe jetzt aber vergessen wie es heißt
was nitro key nee ich weiß es nicht mehr keine ahnung es könnte nitro key gewesen
sein ja kommt mir jetzt auch irgendwie bekannt vor ja warzone ist eines der am schlechtesten
programmiertesten spiele die ich kenne ja gut ich weiß nicht wirklich wie das aussieht
aber die sind viele viele fragwürdige dinge wo du denkst was machen die da ja aber gebe
ich dir recht also 100 fps gerade für wenn man wenn man so ein bisschen irgendwie competitive
ambitionen hat dann ja dann finde ich es auch zu wenig kann so gescheiten monitor empfehlen
bis 250 nee wie gesagt generell bei hardware empfehlung kennen mich ja ich kenne mich damit
genau aus wenn ich mir kauf wenn ich mir kaufe und mich schlau gemacht habe was gerade taugt
und auch nur in der kategorie die ich mir kaufen will
ne ne habe ich nicht was max kannst du mir einspielen was
der war nicht schlecht aber der war auch nur nicht schlecht weil das der eigentliche gag
hinter dem fenster versteckt war hast du dir mal an rate angeschaut ja aber noch nicht
verwendet hast du eine syslogserver empfehlung mit schick im frontend
habe ich nicht aber ich weiß was zurzeit voll im trend ist und zwar was loki log in
logi wie ist das elastic das da ist zurzeit voll im trend
log das ist die andere geschichte log das ist die elastic so etwas geschichte aber das
ist gerade voll angesagt hier loki habe ich noch nie verwendet ist aber gerade bisschen
ist aber gerade etwas gehyped ich kann ja aber da kein persönlich erfahrungsgericht
zu sagen und syslogserver mit frontend kein schimmer ich glaube ich habe daheim noch
nie einen syslogserver verwendet und auf der arbeit haben wir halt einen schick normalen
syslogserver der halt die logs annimmt und dann als techseite entspeichert mittlerweile
haben wir elasticsearch dahinter benutzt jemand wimwiki ne habe ich mir mal angeguckt
hat mir nicht gefallen ich verwende mittlerweile für notizen das hier hat zwei kunde kann
ich auch übrigens jede nur empfehlen ich verwende das hier für notizen erstens es
hat eine kommando zeilen app was ich ziemlich cool finde aber was das halt richtig gut
macht ist es gibt eine android app es gibt eine ios app es gibt eine windows app es gibt
eine mac app eine linux app ich glaube sogar eine web frontend eine kommando zeilen app
und und das ist finde ich so dass das das das das das killer feature was sonst keine
andere app hat neben diesen ganzen clients für jede nur erdenkliche plattform hat es
die möglichkeit notizen zu speichern und to do's inklusive native notifications auf
der jeweiligen plattform also das heißt und dass das kriegt sonst nix gescheit hin ja
dass das kriegt das kriegt sonst nix gescheit hin weil du kannst die apple app kannst du
halbwegs über kall darf sinken für windows gibt es mit kall darf zum beispiel nix wenn
du android hast musst du kall darf dieses kall darf sink ding runterladen was dann dein
kalle also ist es eklig und das schöne daran ist das hat zwar ein eigenes format übrigens
nex cloud sync ist eingebaut geht aber auch über dropbox und alles andere und es hat
halt to do unterstützung mit native notifications das heißt ich schreibe auf meinem auf meiner
linux kiste schreibe ich in der kommando zeilen app oder in in in der elektron frontend halt
das also auf meiner windows kiste schreibe ich in den to do eintrag und sag heute abend
einkaufen 18 uhr 30 und ich editiere den auf meinem linux über die kommando zeile auf
19 uhr und ich bin 19 uhr unterwegs und mein synchronisiertes handy hat eine notification
und bimmelt 19 uhr maximus einkaufen und das ist eine sache die gibt so selbst hosted nirgendwo
droppeln gibt es aber nicht auf efter ist doch scheiß egal das gibt es im offiziellen
store und das ist ziemlich gut also das ist die einzige notiz app schrägstrich to do
app die ich wirklich empfehlen kann der web klipper ist auch übrigens sehr nice wo man
screenshots und links speichern kann das ist die einzige to do app to do also notizen to
do app die ich so als gesamtpaket von features her empfehlen kann eine sache und eigentlich
so ziemlich die einzige sache die mir echt auf den sack geht ist dass die desktop anwendung
elektron sind aber auf der anderen seite die wollen halt ihre anwendung nicht fünf
mal programmieren was ich auch verstehen kann so hast du halt einen to do app die 600 mb
verbraucht weil es elektron ist na gut aber die kann man wirklich empfehlen und gerade
das to do system mit sync über nex cloud und native notification auf allen plattformen
die unterstützt wird eine der wenigen apps die ich kenne die sogar linux wie heißt das
ein notiz ne notify diese winner diese linux desktop notifications unterstützt machen
nicht viele also ist wirklich top ja das muss ich demnächst noch mal ausprobieren ich schreibe
mir das kratz noch mal auf stream ideen stream ideen wo ist es noch mal sind das habe ich
mir nur mal ganz kurz angeguckt so jetzt habe ich alles gcode ja gut bin jetzt eigentlich
stehen geblieben genau das hat das haben wir alles abgehakt was ich für raspberry pi im
einsatz habe mein wort läuft überhaupt nicht im prinzip alles löschen es wurde eine videokamera
von black magic vorgestellt 12k auflösung ok warum nicht ne ne nicht mit z++ syntax
ja wo bin ich denn bevor ich jetzt mich hier in eine nicht rage in sidetrack talk verhindert
habe weiß ich gar nicht wo ich stehen geblieben bin genau ich wollte mir eigentlich wollte
ich mir eine batterie für eine usb kaufen das war best syntax ja das war best syntax
war eine selten benutzte best syntax named pi best syntax wobei die name pi best syntax
ist das dann so also genau ich wollte nämlich mal gucken mal nebenbei eigentlich wollte
ich wirklich mal nebenbei schauen ob ich nicht eine batterie für meine usb kriege denn ich
habe die hier ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen die da habe ich gerade so die übrigens viel
zu teuer ist die war auch günstiger als ich sie gekauft habe also das ist die usb die
ich gerade habe und mein ganzes system da ist ja hängt ja mein ganzes rack dran im endeffekt
auch wenn die hälfte von dem rack nicht mal läuft aber ihr kennt es ja rack ja der da
das da hier unten ist die usb wie man sieht so das ganze rack hing ja da dran und es ist
nicht eine sache bisher ausgefallen jemals jemals nicht eine sache ausgefallen im gesamten
rack seit 2017 bis vor zwei monaten alles tot war und warum weil die usb verreckt ist
das ist natürlich doof also eigentlich hat man da so eine usb weil man möchte dass das
ganze verfügbarer läuft und es ist jetzt kaputt gegangen weil die usb verreckt ist
das hat ziemlich gesagt was genau die usb hat bei mir mal angefangen zu brennen jetzt
ernsthaft echt wirklich zu brennen was ist passiert
warum hat die gebrannt mir wurde eben angezeigt dass du getimet wurde vielleicht habe ich
mich mal wieder irgendwo verklickt ne aber nicht dass ich wüsste weil wenn die anfängt
zu brennen das wäre wirklich schlecht so gibt es dafür irgendwelche neuen akkus ja
diesel genau amazon exakt die kommen da rein so sieht es aus amazon
akku hier battery direct 39 euro das geht ja sogar
hat irgendjemand schon mal battery direct.de bestellt kann man das machen ohne dass es
china batterien sind die direkt um die ohren fliegen
musik ist mega laut
bestellt immer bei all naja also das ist das das ist ja schon unterschied wenn du jetzt
irgendwelche elektronikteile bestellt bei aliexpress ist es das eine aber es gibt es
gibt ein paar sachen die ich nie bei aliexpress bestellen
würde also es gibt ein paar sachen die ich nie bei
aliexpress bestellen würde und dazu gehören zum beispiel batterien und akkus
hab ich schon gedacht das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor jetzt weiß ich auch wo das herkommt
also batterien akkus würde ich nie bei aliexpress bestellen und auch sonst geräte die direkt
in 230 volt steckdose kommen auch nur begrenzt
was könntest du das mit der usv nochmal wieder äh was was äh ja die ist halt kaputt gegangen
und deswegen sind die server meine kisten ausgefallen
kennst du das boot scripting script von microsoft um software auf neue windows 10 aufzusetzen
nein kenne ich kenne ich chat chat ist gut jetzt
ist ja gar nichts mehr suchst du eine offline line interactive
oder was keine ahnung weiß ich kenne ich gar nicht die unterschied
dazwischen echt oh das ist gut
kann man da custom firma flaschen kennst du euch den fluent ui teaser gibt es da ne neuen
na eigentlich will ich gar keine neue bestellen eigentlich reicht mir das wenn ich die akkus
da wenn ich die akkus mal wechseln kann was mich natürlich ein bisschen geschockt hat
bei dieser usv ist also bei der hier was wieder ein bisschen geschockt hat ist warum geht
das komplette rack aus wenn die batterie der usv kaputt geht ich meine der strom ist doch
noch da oder ist es so dass die usv das quasi immer aus der batterie zieht und die batterie
parallel lädt oder so oder wie oder was das habe ich nicht ganz kapiert um ehrlich zu
sein vielleicht läuft der strom permanent durch
die batterie ja dann ist ja kein wunder dass die batterie so schnell kaputt ist oder ja
man kann die firmware flaschen echt das ist ja poggers nein kann man nicht hast du schon
mal es kämpf auf es kämpf auf keckhoff angestellt nein habe ich nicht das habe ich noch sperm
hilfe das haben wir schon geguckt eher worker strom schütt immer durch die batterie geschleift
das wäre zu teuer als anders zu machen echt ok glaube ich dir jetzt einfach mal ich habe
da keine ahnung von das ist mir zu big brain elektronik kram ja ich bestelle mir glaube
ich so eine 40 euro batterie und dann nehme ich das ding wieder in betrieb und gut ist
cap'n peng schreiber battlefield 4 gespielt excellent wish ist ein seriöser laden ja
die heißen aber nicht wisch die heißen wish also mit ohne c usw mit wlan es gibt es gibt
usw die haben so ein management interface und das kannst du über wlan machen apc netzwerkarten
sind hammer teuer ja deswegen finde ich es auch sinnlos dass mit netzwerk mit mit so
eine management interface von der usw zu machen im zweifelsfall nimmt man nämlich den raspberry
zero und stöpselt per usb an und liest das aus das ist besser als eine komische netzwerkkarte
zu kaufen prime oder netflix aktuell prime ich finde netflix ist also ich weiß nicht
ich komme mit den ich finde die meist netflix eigenproduktion jetzt nicht so geil dass ich
mir das deswegen kaufen müsste es für mich ist die witcher serie ein gutes beispiel für
gut genug umgesetzt aber so der letzte der letzte funken springt nicht über gut genug
aber wirklich nicht herausragend umgesetzt ja ganz ok und viele netflix produktion kommen
mir halt vor als sind sie halt ganz ok es gibt mal immer die ein oder anderen sachen
die wohl wirklich richtig gut sind aber die meist netflix produktion sind halt ganz ok
disney plus ist am besten wenn man disney sachen gucken will bestimmt
bei mir ist es halt bin amazon prime so ich bestelle so viel kram bei amazon ich habe
eh schon seit ich glaube ich habe prime seit weiß nicht 2004 oder so seit es das gibt ich
habe ich ich war einer der ersten prime leute behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal ich kann ich
kann es nicht beweisen aber ich habe prime direkt gekauft als es rausgekommen ist damals
und da war es erstens noch billiger und es war halt nur für versandt aber gab es den
ganzen anderen scheiß nicht
nun ja es gibt sonst noch zu sagen warum ist das überhaupt dark mode weil alles alles
mit dark node besser ist 50 euro hat das doch gekostet könnte sein aber im jahr ne ich weiß
noch das erste prime war nicht so teuer und es hat sich richtig gelohnt weil ich damals
auch schon viel bei amazon bestellt habt arbeitest du mit englisch im tastatur layout nein mein
windows ist auf englisch das keyboard layout ist auf deutsch und das liegt daran weil
ich jegliche software sofern es denn irgendwie machbar ist gut funktioniert auf englisch
eingestellt habe denn sobald man einen fehler gibt ist es viel einfacher was zu finden wenn
man nach der englischen fehlermeldung sucht dann statt nach der deutschen
oh jetzt kommt hier big brain oh oh excellent expanding brain schon die cyber power or 6
1 e l c d m r 1 u ist eine line interactive die hat zwar einen spannungsregler aber die
akkus werden nicht die ganze zeit verwendet vielleicht ist auch die usw hinüber also
ich habe die usw danach ausgemacht und wieder angeschlossen und mal eine halbe stunde laufen
lassen ohne was dran zu machen und dann ging es wieder aber sehr merkwürdig auf jeden fall
vielleicht ist die usw auch im arsch ja
also unser postbote der kennt uns mittlerweile auch schon ja also ich muss die straße lang
laufen irgendwo im ort und wenn er unser postbote ist also zumindest der dhl mann und
der was für mich hat kommt da schon gleich an und sagt ja ab was aber mittlerweile ist
es halt so wenn man bei amazon was bestellt die meisten sachen kommen ja gar nicht mehr
per dhl oder dpd oder so die meisten sachen kommen ja mittlerweile mit amazon amazon eigener
logistik und amazon eigene logistik ist schmerzfrei also amazon eigene logistik wirft auch sachen
über den zahn wenn es regnet und so was in der richtung ich kann aber verstehen warum
sie das machen weil sie sich wahrscheinlich denken in den eins zwei prozent der fällen
wenn es hochkommt wo das mal schief geht also die chance dass es schief geht ist so gering
dass es billiger ist wenn man das einfach prinzipiell unordentlich macht als wie wenn
ab und zu mal einer reklamiert
ja also war mir lag das paket mal auf der fensterbank das weiß ich noch auf der fensterbank
obwohl ich nicht da war meine mutter war auch nicht da aber keiner daheim das lag auf der
fensterbank ich bin vom zuch gekommen und sehen paket auf der fensterbank dies war von
mir das hätte jederzeit jeder mitnehmen können ja und wisst ihr was bei amazon immer drinnen
steht bei mir aber amazon steht ja immer da an wen zugestellt wurde also da steht dann
steht meistens ja der bei wem es abgegeben haben und dann steht bei amazon drinnen wenn
sowas ist zugestellt an briefkasten obwohl es irgendwo auf der fensterbank liegt geiles
nur ja aber das nehmen die in kauf das nehmen die in kauf die nehmen kauf dass einmal was
kaputt geht und reklamiert wird anstatt dass sie es bei tausenden leuten ordentlich machen
müssen moment ich glaube es war sogar unterschrieben von briefkasten ich glaube es war sogar sowas
in der richtung wir unterschrieben von briefkasten es war was ganz merkwürdig wo ich wo ich
mir immer noch drüber kaputt lachen kann gut das hat ja jeder das dhl manchmal nicht
klingelt das ist übrigens auch ein grund warum ich mittlerweile an der klingelnde kamera
next gen smart home nimmt auch pakete an sowas gibt es schon und so blöd es klingt von
der telekom paket sack war das der paket butler was ist da los
paket butler anscheinend anscheinend gibt es das nicht mehr weil ich mache das jetzt
nicht auf wer so fail ist und als business kein gültiges zertifikat macht der hat sich
verdient dass ich auf die seite gehe von jemand dabei erwischt bis jetzt nicht nein
aber ich habe die kamera auch erst drei monate zwei drei monate oder so dabei ist letztendlich
zu easy aber die sind wahrscheinlich besser die nehmen wahrscheinlich kein letztendlich
die nehmen europen ssl also überhaupt nicht was das ist
weg tigo what europen ssl oi netik gmbh in durmersheim baden-württemberg aha alles klar
alles klar das war mal komodo wird ja immer schlimmer
seck tigo seck tigo ist ja gut die haben einfach vergessen neues zertifikat auszustellen
tja es passiert den besten ja wobei ich nicht sagen möchte dass sie zu den besten gehört
gibt es eigentlich noch irgendeinen grund eine andere ca als letzten kript zu nutzen
mehr sicherheit oder so da kriegt ein ziemlich gute frage ja ja wenn man keine keine webseiten
also keine ssl zertifikate haben will also wenn man zum beispiel co-signing zertifikate
und so braucht aber ansonsten fällt mir da kein richtiger grund mehr ein
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert aber demnächst steht auch mal ein kubanete stream an
nutze zertbot zertbot ist letzten kript
zertbot ist quasi zum letzten kript ausstell script
aber mir fällt jetzt kein grund ein ehrlich gesagt warum man was anderes also bei uns
auf der arbeit ist es so wir haben ein team was unter anderem für zertifikate zuständig
ist also für bestellen und die mögen letzten kript überhaupt nicht aber die können mir
nichts sinnvolles erklären warum sie letzten kript nicht mögen ich glaube der eigentliche
grund warum die letzten kript nicht mögen ist folgendes
weil letzten kript non-profit ist und man sie dafür eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte
zumal man letzten kript halt auch super automatisieren kann ich glaube die haben ein bisschen schiss
um ihre aufgabe als zertifikat menschen bei uns einen weiteren kund erkenne ich da eigentlich
nicht warum die so gegen letzten kript sind da eine argumentiert immer damit so nach dem
motto ja das vertrauen wäre höher warum
ist das vertrauen höher als wird sich irgendwie ein normaler user kennt ihr irgendwer ernsthaft
habt ihr irgendwo bei einem normalen user schon mal gesehen dass der sich die details
von dem zertifikat überhaupt anguckt dass der überhaupt weiß dass man sich das hier
anzeigen lassen kann das das weiß doch das macht doch kein normaler user also ist das
auch nicht vertrauen zu wissen bekommt man bei letzten kript weiter ja ja bekommst du
kein problem kannst du ausstellen lassen machen die den ganzen tag nichts anderes als zertifikat
doch die machen noch andere sachen zum beispiel was die auch noch machen neben zertifikaten
ist die restlichen systeme die wir haben mit lotus notes betreiben ja lotus notes in 2020
so sieht es aus wir haben noch lotus notes an manchen stellen aber ansonsten ich glaube
noch ein paar windows system oder so frag mich nicht was die genau machen bitte bitte
was für notes lotus lotus ibm lotus notes heißt es jetzt anders hcl domino heißt es
jetzt anders was ist das
ach die haben das verkauft ja das für das hätte ich das hätte ich auch gemacht an
ibm stelle das hätte ich an ibm stelle auch gemacht also ich frag mich nur eher wer ist
so dumm und kauft den scheiß also sowohl als anwender aber aber als besitzer ok was
ist hcl technologies das sind bestimmt chinesen oder so wow germany war an die offices indische
in die inder den inder gehört jetzt lotus notes alles klar wird er immer besser
wahrscheinlich waren es die einzigen die sie überhaupt übernommen haben ich glaube
es nicht da schüttelt sich ja bei mir alles wenn ich an lotus notes denke die wollen
bestimmt lange long term support abgreifen ja die vermutung habe ich auch naja ja scheint
so ja nächsten sonntag ich glaube ich gehe ziemlich klar auf weil morgen neun uhr acht
uhr dreißig der schulungsmann ist ultra motiviert der hier der schulungsmann der das macht der
hat gesagt ok es geht eigentlich erst um neun uhr los aber für alle die es interessiert
macht er so einen kleinen powershell kurs acht uhr dreißig der ist die motivation in
person der typ und ich denke mir so warum ich will ein bisschen ruhe ich will neun uhr
es ok ja nicht so dass es mich nicht interessieren würde aber ich meine ich gehe noch nicht
ich stehe noch nicht extra früh auf um eine halbe stunde mir powershell zeigen zu lassen
dass ich da wieder bis 17 uhr asher machen kann powershell pence champ ich muss euch sagen
und das sage ich als ultra hier linux fan und und jemand der mit linux quasi sein geld
verdient powers übrigens bei dabei wusstet ihr dass es powershell auch für für linux
mittlerweile gibt warum auch immer man das machen möchte ich muss euch sagen als linux
fan ich finde powershell nicht schlecht powershell ist eine richtige kack interaktive shell also
hier zum benutzen ist powershell müll sobald allein schon dass es kaum sachen gibt die
eingebaut sind also du hast kaum sinnvolle kommandos um damit was zu machen aber also
im täglichen interaktiven betrieb aber wofür powershell wirklich gut ist für sachen automatisieren
unter windows na gut da ist es auch irgendwo konkurrenzlos weil da gibt es nichts anderes
man betsch betsch ja ok aber ganz ehrlich wer ist wirklich 2020 wer gibt sich noch
betsch aber da ist powershell gar nicht mal so übel powershell hat auch ein bisschen
anderen ansatz als besch in besch ist ja alles text also wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal hier
so date mache und möchte mir dann da irgendwas rausgreppen ist bescheuert ist nur eine zeile
ja so dann ist der output von date text und geht in input als text input an grepp so so
ist das in besch in der powershell ist das anders in der powershell wenn du von einem
cmd let's build in befehl wie auch immer man das genau nennt es von einem befehl zum
anderen befehl weiter gibst dann sind das echte dotnet objekte auf die man auch zugreifen
kann nicht einfach nur text das ist für automatisierung sehr sehr nice aber für interaktiv ist irgendwie
crap bei uns wird noch bettsch benutzt um sich ja geht wenn es software die cnc maschinen
bedient die laufen wahrscheinlich auch noch in der windows 95 da wundert mich das nicht
mehr powershell sequin je nachdem für was sequin ist ziemlich ja kraft zum größten
teil ja das stimmt aber trotzdem ist besch eine bessere interaktive shell als powershell
xp ja irgendwie sowas
nee ich glaube es spricht man mit sequin oder so aus kein schimmer wie man zu quinn
ausspricht sequin sequin zu quinn wie sagt der switcher wie sagt das war in der schweizer
so zu quinn oder so keine ahnung ja das ist unter unter windows so ein bisschen eklig
bevor ich powershell nutze leute näher aber du kannst damit nicht das gleiche machen
ich meine powershell hast du gerade mit dem mit den cmd led erweiterung kannst du saumäßig
viele bild in sachen also hast du saumäßig viele sachen für windows automatisierung
die du halt in pyson nicht hast pyson kannst du die meisten sachen auch machen musst du
halt manuell machen muss dann irgendwelche wmi abfragen machen machen oder irgendwelche
registry geschichten oder was auch immer also powershell ist schon gut wenn man windows
automatisieren will ja windows ist case sensitive weil auch nicht genau warum was mit denen
los ist windows willst du machen machst du nix
übrigens zu windows dateisystem fällt mir auch noch was tolles ein wir haben bei uns
in unserem haupt repo dort wo auch der puppet code für die server liegt dort haben wir
und zwar hier genau case da geht es gerade rum dort haben wir eine datei liegen die nennt
sich konn punkt pp kann sich jemand denken was das problem unter windows mit der datei
ist
konn ist reserved ja du kannst unter windows keine datei anlegen die konn in irgendwie
im dateinamen hat also zum beispiel konn punkt txt specified device name is invalid konn
punkt blub geht nicht du darfst unter windows da sind irgendwelche ollen dos über bleibsel
du kannst unter windows keine datei anlegen die konn im dateinamen hat also die die ja
im datei teil vom dateinamen hat geht nicht da hat natürlich keiner dran gedacht weil
wir das alle unter linux angelegt haben und dann haben die ersten leute das war unter
windows geklont und gett hat immer rumgemerkert datei gelöscht warum soll er die datei gelöscht
sein du hast doch gerade frisch geklont dati gelöscht also konn pp windows reserviert
auks geht auch nicht ok das muss ich aber das wusste man als linux mann weiß man das
nicht unbedingt und das hat uns schon öfters genervt wie das ist wieder so eine richtig
typische windows ppega geschichte die wahrscheinlich keiner mehr verwendet aber einfach nur da
ist übrigens leute wollen wir uns mal temple os angucken hat letztens im stream einer
geschrieben ich soll mir mal temple os angucken das ist für die besonders christliche leute
unter uns temple os mit so einer tollen oberfläche hier die richtig big brain oberfläche aber
die story um temple os die habe ich mal gelesen die ist sogar relativ ppe ppe hans weil der
entwickler ultra gläubiger typ sein der ist 2018 vom zug überfahren worden der entwickler
hier der entwickler von temple os der ist irgendwo steht doch genau der ist 2018 bevor
er noch eine version rausbringen konnte ist da quasi vom zug überfahren worden mal gucken
ob es weitere temple os versionen was zum teufel ist der dritte temple ok was auch immer ja
so sieht es aus temple os big guns also genau das was man eigentlich unter einem christlichen
betriebssystem ja nun mal als erstes erwarten würde big guns vielleicht meint er auch das
damit ich weiß nicht er nicht hatte er kein schimmer hatte ich habe keine ahnung ich weiß
nur dass er vom zug überfahren wurden temple es wurde von den uns techtipps vorgestellt
na dann ist doch jetzt gerade weiß doch die halbe it welt oder auch die noob welt die also
viele richtige hardcore it leute gucken es ja gar nicht bescheid was temple os ist dann
wird es mal zeit dass wir uns temple os auch mal im stream angucken machen wir ja stream
idee nicht video idee stream idee temple os temple os gibt es das eigentlich auf github
mittlerweile jetzt wo der typ gestorben ist nicht dass keiner den code hat
aber warum nicht bis zu 64 bit das müsste doch eigentlich bei den amis voll beliebt
sein die sind doch alle so ultra gläubig oder bei den spaniern auch die spanier doch
auch wenn es temple os gibt gibt es auch muschee os oder sowas oder imam os jetzt bestimmt
jetzt bestimmt alles oder hier das dings hier wie heißen die typen noch mal die erzählen
dass die dinosaurien nicht älter als 50.000 jahre sind das bei den amis auch voll beliebt
wie heißen die noch mal die behaupten das ist alles verarschung und und die welt ist
irgendwie die dinosaurien sind 50.000 jahre die welt ist irgendwie vor 100.000 jahren entstanden
oder sowas kreationisten die creation ja ja ja genau die genau die ja die meine ich die
brauchen auch sowas aber das ist wieder so eine typische sache sowas kann sich nur bei
den kokoners durchsetzen ob er sagt kann man nicht sagen kann man nicht sagen blödsinnige
sachen sagen so religiöse getriebenen blödsinnigen sachen das schaffen sie überall auf der
welt das ist nicht dass es nicht kokona gibt es gibt es genug kreationisten gibt es überall
keine ahnung ich habe es ja erst mal gar nicht für möglich gehalten dass es so leute
überhaupt gibt aber wenn man nachkommt die gibt es wirklich hohle erne hohle erne ist
nicht mal so angesagt flat earth ist eher so aktuell weil eins muss man ja sagen flat
earth und hohle erne verträgt sich nicht also das ist sogar für die größten verschwörungstheorie
leute passt das nicht zusammen weil wenn die erde flach ist kann er die erde nicht hohl
sein weil weil wo soll die hohl sein wenn sie flach ist da ist ja kein platz
also keine ahnung die ist also flat earth ist grad eher angesagt als hohle erde als
ja genau als hohle erde was ich was mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
wundern weil ich glaube dass hohle erde die lange zeit die etabliertere verschwörungstheorie
war und jetzt erst in letzter zeit flat earth mir das so richtig da aufkommt auch nicht
playlists eins
gut mal unabhängig jetzt von irgendwelche verschwörungstheorien das
gucken wir uns demnächst an ab hohle erde noch nie gehört das ist das ist grad nicht
die präferierte verschwörungstheorie aber ich hab es ja schon oft gesagt ich finde wir
sollten zu vielen sachen ein bisschen weniger vor voreilig verschwörungstheorie sagen wo man
das noch nicht so genau weiß ja also bei flat earth mag es was anderes sein aber ich finde
es ist bei den meisten sachen zumindest nicht verkehrt sich mal die argumenten der anderen
seite anzuhören wobei man halt gerade über flat earth sagen muss also wenn man sich denn
anhört kommt da auch nicht allzu viel sinnvolles rum ja 5g 5g und und corona und bill gates ist
natürlich auch von angesagt gibt's auch flat mooner da habe ich jetzt noch nichts von gehört
aber ich denke mal wenn die wenn die erde flach ist dann muss der mond wahrscheinlich auch flach
sein weil ansonsten wird es ja auch keinen sinn ergeben weiß ich nicht genau schon mal ein video
im task manager rennen dann sehen ja so ziemlich bei jedem video was ich bisher gemacht habe
ist kein bock drauf
oh moment was ist
oh das ist ja geil das ist ja geil pixel auslastung pixel einfärben über cpu ko auslastung im task
manager ich glaube ich fange jetzt noch einen pass of exile character an und level noch eine
stunde und nämlich noch nan cast und gritt frost nova stelzer basteln nachdem ich genug
währung gesammelt habe ich habe ich schon wieder viel zu viele pass of exile stunden
diesen diesmal eigentlich voll der primäre du farmen sie ein ab kommst so auf um die also
wenn man mal sagt was ich pass of exile jetzt so um die fünf exhalts ungefähr in währung gerade und
dann guckst du dir bei einem china shop nach da kostet exalted irgendwie 50 cent oder so was wo
ich mir denke ok da müssen aber viele chinesen in irgendwelchen containern den ganzen tag farmen
dass ich das lohnt
brauchst du ein coaching von headhunter spielern nachdem ich kein headhunter habe ich eigentlich
auch kein headhunter bild spielen will auch ich auch kein coaching von den handtas spieler
letztens clip gesehen du bist da ist hat einer gestreamt und auch mit dem chat gelabert und
geht dann so über irgendwelche drops und und sieht also beim vorbeiziehen vom auszeigen das
gerade headhunter gürtel getroppt ist also bla bla bla chat bla bla bla ich muss ja sagen die
pass of exile community so so toxic dass in game im main chat teilweise aussieht ich muss ehrlich
sagen dass die twitch community echt sehr freundlich ist da wird zwar aus da wird sich
natürlich auch ein abgemimt was sonst was ist aber nachdem es halt kein competitive pvp spiel
ist sind die leute echt freundlich zueinander sowohl die streamer als auch der chat hätte ich so
gar nicht erwartet muss man echt mal sagen ein ganzes projekt nur mit single character
copy paste nein oh was ist das da schaum ich oh firmware update für den elektroroller
poggers das sind leute wir haben es geschafft 2020 man mordet die firmware von seinem elektroroller
poggers läuft pass of exile auf einem t was ist da für eine grafikkarte drin
inter integrated ja laufen schon wobei man sagen muss gerade im endgame maps mit vielen
vielen mobs drauf je nach skillung ist das schon ziemlich slowdowns drin ich finde das geil dass
man die firmware von seinem elektroroller monnen kann heute jetzt wo ich gesagt habe ich gehe
jetzt auf instant 70 leute weg aber kann ich auch verstehen weil warum erzähle ich aber ich gehe
offen geht er nicht oft total hängen geblieben ja du kannst mal davon abgesehen im 079 probiere
sein voraus der download ist nicht so riesengroß das ist jetzt kein warzone und kostet nix probiere
es einfach mal aus also ich glaube nicht dass es jetzt super geil drauf laufen wird gerade auch im
endgame du kannst mal ausprobieren ich würde zumindest darauf verzichten irgendwelche spellslinger
necro vd sonst was geschichten zu spielen zu spielen weil das kack auf meiner 1080 ti hat das
teilweise frame einbrüche soll das irgendwas nicht ganz so effektintensives spielen so wie
dem auch sei ich gehe jetzt wirklich auf leute macht's gut co macht's gut bis denn